BUKOLA AYODELE: Hi, I'm Bukola.
And today, I'm super
excited to talk
about delivering high-performing
global APIs with Apigee
and Cloud CDN.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
With the power of digital, many
organizations across industries
are going global to unlock new
markets and optimize costs.
As businesses expand
their global footprints,
they need to deliver connected
customer experiences,
integrate seamlessly
with regional partners,
and equip global
distributed workforces.
APIs are packages of
data and functionality
that power digital experiences,
both customer-facing and
employee-facing.
Therefore, as you
go global, it is
imperative to scale
your API programs.
To help you globalize
your API initiatives,
Google Cloud brings together
Apigee and Cloud CDN,
the best of API management
and content delivery network
solutions.
While Apigee builds a solid
foundation for your APIs,
Cloud CDN brings you the
same edge points of presence
that Google uses to serve its
web properties to billions
of users.
By extending the power of
Cloud CDN to your APIs,
you can host your APIs across
24 regions in 73 zones,
reduce the latency of
your APIs with caching
at more than a
hundred locations,
and increase the availability
for peak traffic seasons.
Let's see a quick demo
of how this works.
For the purpose
of this demo, I've
created a Hello
World API in Apigee.
To protect this API, let's first
start by adding a Verify API
Key to this proxy.
Once we do that, you'll see the
default is set to a queryparam,
but let's change
this to a header.
I'm now going to save
it as a new revision
and deploy it to the
demo environment.
To consume this API, let's
create an API product
and add our API proxy to this
product by specifying the path.
With this, the Hello World proxy
is now ready and accessible.
Now let's see how to
apply Cloud CDN to improve
the caching of this API to
better serve global consumers.
I created a very
simple Cloud CDN policy
and attached it to
a load balancer.
I also pick the most basic
configuration for this policy.
When I go to the
load balancer, you
can see that Cloud
CDN is enabled.
I need to make one minor
addition to my API proxy
to let Cloud CDN know that
the response to this API
needs to be cached.
When I access the
proxy from us-west,
the call is executed in
about 10 milliseconds.
If I take the same
call and execute it
from a VM located
in europe-west,
the response time for
this first attempt
is about 215 milliseconds.
However, because of
enhanced caching,
the response time for
the second attempt
goes down to 16 milliseconds.
That was just a
quick preview of how
to deliver high-performing
global APIs with Apigee
and Cloud CDN.
In summary, Apigee and Cloud CDN
offer integrated out-of-the-box
capabilities to scale and
deliver high-performing APIs.
Now it's your turn
to try it out and get
started by following the links
in the description box below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]